here's a funny little story for a Friday
hilarious story actually
the actress Mila Kunis you might know
her from the movie forgetting sarah
marshall you might remember her from
that 70s show or maybe stuff she's acted
in more recently I don't know what she's
been doing you also might recognize her
more recently if you watch TV from Jim
Beam commercials Jim Beam is quite
frankly a mediocre bourbon whiskey I
don't know too many people that would
disagree with me on that but okay they
hired Mila Kunis to do ads for them and
some of the ads are actually kind of
clever and funny and it turns out that
Mila Kunis is also a big progressive she
was recently on the Conan O'Brien
late-night talk show and she said to
Conan on his show that she doesn't like
Vice President Mike Pence's politics so
that she's been I guess kind of
protesting she's been resisting Mike
Pence expressing her disgust I think is
a better word a better way to say by
making monthly donations to the family
planning organization known as Planned
Parenthood in Mike Pence's name all
right so she makes the donation but in
Pence's name to Planned Parenthood and
she said to Conan I disagreed with some
of the stuff that Mike Pence was doing
and trying to do and so as a reminder
that there are women out here in the
world that may or may not agree with his
platform I put him on a list of
recurring donations that are made in his
name to Planned Parenthood
people are now boycotting Jim Beam
because as because of the donations that
Mila Kunis makes to Planned Parenthood
in Mike Pence's name the anti-choice
errs on Twitter are apoplectic trying to
shame Jim Beam into dropping Mila Kunis
as a spokesperson threatening to or
claiming that they're boycotting Jim
Beam until they fire me like Mila Kunis
so far Jim Beam at least as of a few
hours ago Jim Beam has not commented
about the controversy I never buy Jim
Beam I never drink Jim Beam
but if Jim Beam did comment and defend
Mila Kunis I might be inclined to go out
and grab a couple bottles of Jim Beam
and keep it in my bar just as
show of solidarity and here's the
funniest part of the entire story
some of the boycotters I guess in an
effort to be useful are suggesting some
alternatives to Jim Beam in order to
make the boycott easier right they are
trying to make it so that if you really
like Jim Beam and you're worried if I
boycott Jim Beam what am I gonna drink
they're saying hey here's some
alternatives you can get booker's you
can get Knob Creek or basil Hayden a
bunch of them and it turns out that a
lot of the recommendations as
replacements for Jim Beam are made by
the same parent company that makes Jim
Beam how great is that you go through
all the trouble of boycotting and loudly
expressing your disdain for Jim Beam
over a political disagreement and the
recommendations you make for people who
might want to partake are
recommendations that put money into the
exact same parent company I love it are
you boycotting Jim Beam let me know i'm
on twitter at des Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we have
a tremendous program for you today